okay yes one o'clock yeah yes
for starters I've ordered wasabi horns
and soft-shell crab but I'm going to
change my order once I've seen that he's
put it through and I'm gonna order the
lamb shank
sorry can I change my order started from
I'd like their lamb shank
yes thank you Judah Mingo okay hi sorry
I asked to swap for lamb shank
well yeah but what's the additional
order you won't know this yeah yeah
right sorry thank you so the kitchens
ended up cooking an extra dish because
the way to never said that it was an
exchange that's why he didn't come ask
seems to be a bit of a lack of
communication between some of the front
passed our own kitchen what goes through
your mind when you see that the burners
uh I think part of the reason why we
made a mistake is because it's not
unusual for somebody to have three
starters between two people oh my
goodness in a martini glass that's not
what I was expecting
Wow thank you did I read the many right
that there's no resemblance to the dish
that I was reading about I'm like sorry
I just I can't believe it that's what I
ordered is that the one you say the fire
being weird kind of the soft-shell crab
instead thank you
it wasn't clear from the menu at all
that that's what that dish comes like
why are we serving lamb shank in a
martini glass that's hot it just seemed
so strange and such a bizarre thing to
do
ah it's a fair fancy doctor fantasy
starter Jesus
flaming tableside I thought the pork was
first to arrive
flaming No Oh was it there I missed it
great dramatic session really really
great and romantic and they do it at the
customer pack I can't see it my guest
spots it really pointless I said words
that happen sorry just find the issue we
have for the Chinese rice wine flaming
is that very often the flames are quite
hard to see no one can see the [ __ ]
flame because it doesn't give off a lot
of flame it's a little bit of fun it's a
bit of showmanship I don't see anything
wrong with that there's a consistent
strand true here that you're trying to
be clever with the martini glass the
lamb shank and now you've on buying
something that it's got nothing to do
with flavor don't damage what you got by
trying to be too clever prize yes
that's extraordinarily kind of ramming
the dishes have been delicious
that's really kind thank you now that's
somebody who clean prides himself on the
service they feel they ought to offer
food they want to hit the table it has
to be perfect or they're not happy
including or after ok and brilliantly
handle at the ends offering the whole
thing on the house I think the the
emotion I feel right now is more
determination than disappointment you've
got to get your head down and make
things better I hope we can now mean